reader what the purpose of life brother
Eddie gonna show you all the show
bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
that's the greeting of peace peace be
unto you welcome to another episode of
the Deen show I'm excited very excited
that you can see I'm even sweating and
it's not too hot in here I'm just
excited and you're gonna be excited
because we bring you a treat once in a
while and this is that time that we're
going to bring you another treat
we have Hussein ye who is here on the
Deen show who's going to be telling us
his story on how he came to Islam when
we come back here in the Deen show you
don't want to go nowhere
and with us here on adine so share
hussein ye sow alikum walaikum Salaam
rahmatullahi wa barakaatuh peace be unto
you and to you too right now see they
looking at you and they think you know
this is my Aggie son you might do some
special move here so they were so are
you involved in martial arts yeah on an
obvious in child now were you the one
that starred in The Karate Kid
that was a very very popular movie
yeah and they used to have it was Miyagi
he was like the Grand Master and you had
Karate Kid so he came to what they were
picking on him bullying them and and
people remember wax on wax off this is
it every every Hirata is Baraka every
well I mean every movement there's
always some blessing yes yes masha'Allah
you have a unique story because you came
from a Buddhist background is that it
yes now so the viewers now we get to
speak to a lot of people who came from
the Christian background but now this is
unique I've actually never interviewed
someone who came from a Buddhist
background now talk to us tell us a
little bit about your story before Islam
and Hum Dil I've been been born from a
Chinese family with no maturity a
Chinese the Buddhist or how did their
arteries or Buddhist and some of my
family members their Buddhist and as a
Buddhist we know that
if he understand the teaching of Gotama
buddha then you understand how this word
Buddha derive from mm-hmm now it arrived
from the word of boot meaning before go
atomic um been enlightened so he was
looking for something the Buddha Buddha
what was his real name
Guatemala so it's Guatemala it's named
after then after is Buddha is not his
name Buddha is a title given to him what
does that I don't mean the title derived
from the word boot means the awakening
awakening awakening there he was looking
for something so it say his name again
one more time go I can't man what Rama
yeah he was looking for something from
some kind of enlightenment okay so the
awakening of him looking for something
that is missing in his life is called
boot bundestag excrete wood and that
again means would mean awakening
awakening awakening so he had an
awakening Abood yeah he had the boot the
boot and later on he wore he got to
leave the palace because he's a he was a
preemie or he was a prince was a praying
so he had the cash and money I have but
he's missing something is missing in the
spiritual team yes so he knows something
is missing in his life
uh-huh no so he left the palace and this
way he start his journey the journey to
look for the truth and he was he
encountered a lot of other Hermes or
so-called sames at that time people who
isolate themselves in the in the forest
you know just by themself
keeping their head long that news uncut
no but he's not attracted to the kind of
practice
yes if there is it's not real so he was
looking and looking and nobody can
explain to him nobody can give him
guidance and that's why he meditate and
Abu tree what kind of tree a poetry they
call a boot yeah because if you go back
to the history of all these prophets all
prophet will have to go to this color
they call Kahlua means that kind of
seclusion seclusion and so what happened
to Guatemala tating under the bow tree
looking for an answer
looking for something he wanted to know
the real life what is life after death
and from there he was enlightened and
one he received the Enlightenment then
he was given the title Buddha what was
this enlightenment that he had that he
experienced that he he understand what
is life now he know what is that life is
the mission it's something that you must
do here before you meet the Almighty God
so he believed in a god believed in God
because know is so interesting before
you come to understand about Buddhism
normally people say Gautama Buddha
Buddha they have nothing to do with God
he's a way of life now hold on you were
like a were you actually like a what do
you call a monk like not really among
but I do get involve any closer you were
very involved so you knew that their
teachings very well yeah now how were
you because you are obviously looking to
get enlightened so before you learned
all of this what was your what was your
faith before now I was as a Chinese
descendant you obviously mix you have
that Buddhist owies and also some of us
are Christian later I become a Christian
so what were you for what was your
family your mother and father maybe I
ought of Buddhist Buddhist so you were
born into a Buddhist family Woody's
family okay so now the Buddhist family
okay they're following these teachings
but this is very interesting because
like you said I want I want to if you
can elaborate on this a little more
because most Buddhists they say that
there is no God yeah so this is false no
this is not true this is what we thought
yes but that's nothing to do with the
teaching of Guatemala if you are fair
enough to go back to the history of of
Gautama Buddha then you will come to a
conclusion that he do not denied God
you gotta go back and study there in his
Dharma that the teaching of Gautama
Buddha is always called Dharma
that's Dharma is the doctrine that's
their doctrine a doctrine okay they're
books they have their book there are
many books but normally we talk about
books they talk about Dharma uh-huh and
then if you look at this teaching the
Dharma are we start with karma karma
karma karma if you look in the teach the
Islamic term is about faith about what
is being effected by God you just got to
accept now what is going to happen to
you but we always what they teach is
like what goes around comes around this
is like the Karma yeah yeah is it like
you do something good at the end of day
you'll be rewarded accordingly yes is
the only day they they explain in a
different ways but all come back to the
other and other if you compare with what
Islam say about karma is a kadhai and
other so what we say is the destiny same
thing is the Karma
okay let's hold off right there we're
going to take a break and we right back
on the D show
there always be someone that'll be there
to say something negative but at the
same time there'll be someone there to
say something positive awesome just hold
on to the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe can rely I need a lot the
Quran says don't kill women don't kill
children don't kill old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told him of you know
Allah said that the Prophet SAW Allah
never ever stopped a war back here with
Sheikh Hussein ye now tell us sheikh
please how deeply were you involved in
Buddhism if I look back to my lifestyle
yeah from young I'd like to get
involving all this spiritual kind of
thing
and the best way to get involved is to
serve the temple there's a best way the
memory in the temple you're close to the
monk you're close to all these so-called
religious people yes
who can explain to you more about know
what the teaching of Gautama Buddha is
about was he like a prophet to them or
what was he do they look at him as God
to them before they look at them and I
can lead a spiritual leader okay they
don't call him prophet actually and
they're like their master gurus so they
call like the Guru their gurus now yeah
but later on what happened people start
to worship Him later this is way higher
cost made late and like the Chinese
today majority D if they want to
or something we'll go to the temple the
Buddhist temple and they start to call
his name and ask some kind of blessing
through him did he ever tell people to
do that no no not in his time you never
allow anybody to worship Him or he never
claimed himself as God you know all that
he have some kind of God she believed no
correct me if I'm wrong I'm just coming
to the Assumption because you're our
teacher so please if I say anything
that's not correct we in Islam we
believe that over 124 thousand
messengers were sent is it possible that
this might have been a messenger that
had called people to pure monotheism is
it possible to my understanding yeah I
one said that everybody should believe
what I feel what do you have to my own
research after coming to Islam and I
compared back to the teaching the
towhead of Islam and the teaching of
Gautama I don't see any difference and
and I believe that what a loss of hand
houghton did inform us well acaba
osmotically
Amaterasu land and net would a lowest
Animoto good indeed allah say we have
sent to all nations
a messenger rasool messenger whose duty
is to invite people to believe in one
god and to stay away from all other gods
they mean no idol-worshipping
human achievement shaytan while you call
devil worshipping no you worship only
one God and like what you said early you
say that the Prophet they said that the
120,000 of Prophet it's been Sam only
majority of the name is not been known
to - even the Prophet Muhammad SAW
Muslim and it was stated in the Quran -
they allow him from our prophet that
there are many prophets there are life
saying that his name also Allah did not
inform our prophets of Muslim and only
our prophecy two hundred and twenty
thousand of them so so from your
investigation as possible obviously
but over time people change his
teachings it's just like what happened
to the to the Christianity with Jesus if
Jesus he had a claim that he was God the
same thing happens yeah but people
worshipping him now people are
worshiping him yeah the same thing what
is happening to a lot of other people
are the so-called cult group they are
worshiping their gurus they worshiping
their leaders yeah where all these good
people normally like I'm talking about
Guatemala never in his lifetime he allow
anybody to worship Him never one he
claimed that he is God neither he denied
God because he do pray dance prostration
yeah in the teaching of God that one
where can they go now someone's a
Buddhist okay and we are trying to reach
out to the whole of humanity because
caring is sharing so we're trying to
share the truth so where can they go now
to look to to verify some of these
things the best way is they must come
back to the Quran the Quran is the final
book yes without going back to the Quran
then it's not easy for you to know what
is right what is wrong or onions not
something new is here to confirm what
was revealed to the early prophets
culture there's very important that's
why it is a blessing yet that we Muslim
is have the Quran but is unfortunately a
lot of people who are not yet Muslim
don't have the opportunity to read the
Quran maybe because most women do not
encourage them to read or maybe they are
afraid yeah you see their favorite there
are people that I have some dozen
sisters who I offer her Quran I see I
can read your Bible
can you read my Quran that's from the
devil they'll say have you read this
yeah something that energy no no no no
please don't give me a book like the
course because we will be reminded you
know there's some maybe some magic day
yeah no craziness it's just a book yeah
I mean I read every other book is this
book just be open about it yeah so we
believe that if people will open their
heart
be sincere body just read what is
written
in the quran then they will find it true
the Islam is not here to tell you that I
mean islami God that we believe Allah he
is not the lord of the Arabs Oh God to a
particular nation or tribe unlike his
his he is telling us about himself he's
here allah rabbul aalameen allah is the
creator of the universe he is not rubble
Arab or rahbaniya at the pad particle
nation Pakistani or so on but his Rumble
al-amin means the Creator the sustainer
of the universe not everything along
everything so this is the god that moses
god of Jesus Qasim Adam God of Abraham
God or Buddha yeah I got a Buddha but
tell us now let's go back a little bit
so you mentioned Christianity so you
were born into a mother father family of
Buddhist and then did you go and become
a Christian yes now talk to us about -
how did this happen now no you see when
we are young at the time when we look
out deeper to the teaching of Gautama
teaching of Buddhism you find that
there's a lot of donors a lot of tone
that mean you go for pure vegetarian
example Buddhist you see meat no meat no
me no meat because now this is not from
the teacher of Guam and now this also
something yes there are addition
cultural influences yes that because
they are very close to Hinduism yeah you
know because even Gautama is from India
yeah so they have the influence of these
vegetarian Clairol thing of course they
have good intention they said that if
you eat a lot of meat it's very
difficult for you to control your desire
your destructive design there goes the
first thing yeah five pillars of Islam
everything is it but it's not it's it's
it's it's been distorted it's not
another partially here and there but
when look into Islam Islam cover
everything yes
that's why we see is now is a complete
thing Allah say a glioma
Campina come today I have perfected this
religion for you hamdulillah that is how
the difference between the early Dion
and Islam because Islam is easier to
complete and to perfect what is not been
perfected before this yes so if you look
carefully about the teaching of Gautama
I mean to be fair to this man
you will never find anything that he
said against the tow him against the
pure monotheism one God one God not
three-in-one for my lord no God no God
man under this stuff God having children
none of this no not this ok of this and
also you see what he was his main
teaching is divided into two the suka
and the dr. su karna dukkha whatever
suka means glad tiding okay that means
good news good news and the come is a
warning the one if you reject the
message yes now you go back to Islam
same thing here the same thing they
Allah sent the prophets to bring to news
bashira wanna 0 good news and bad news
good news for those who respond and
accept the truth they come from one God
the God of every one of us the bad thing
is if you reject me
that means you choose not to believe in
the true god yes it's not good for you
of course because the end of the day
like you do not appreciate what a lot of
almighty you he'll give you everything
in return you go against him it's not
good for everybody
so soccer and dukkha if you look into
that it's just like bashira 1.0 yes so
but because of the there are so many
Vida involved - and the dawn is more
than they do it make life very difficult
for people who are very young age so
that was unity that's me too many rules
and regulations it's not easy it's time
it's time I mean
no woman at the terminal no lady you
cannot have any relation with the
opposite sex yeah you just isolate
yourself get close to the Almighty and
then you got to learn how to back how to
be humble and now they learn how to walk
barefoot no all this teaching if you go
back to the Quran it will grow else it
will Adam Schiff in our tomorrow ha
don't walk on the earth of the on this
land with pride yeah be humble how do
they teach the people to be humble you
must take out your shoes so you can say
it's kind of going to an extreme now no
I'm saying that they are here to prepare
yeah to prepare the people to get ready
for the coming revolution yeah it's like
Moses prepare his people before coming
of Jesus
yeah and Jesus is preparing his people
for the coming of Prophet Muhammad's
impossible so that so of course this is
more on that the way to prepare people
from one stage to another stage yeah and
then when country Islam is complete okay
let's hold off right there we got to
take another break share and we right
back with more the story here on the D
show a single unambiguous treatment the
Jesus Christ peace be upon you insisted
that I am God I'm British oppression
comes to you the truth and the attribute
of the one who created you that he's one
and alone running this universe that he
doesn't become born he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom this
is not God problem yeah it's this it
doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshipping resembles this
is recorded in the Gospels despite all
of the other issues about the Gospels we
put those aside with the Saints
mentioned Jesus back here on a Dean show
with Sheikh saying ye so now too many
rules and we're learning a little bit
about Buddhism and we're being
enlightened to know that hey there's
pure monotheism in there and a lot of
similarities to Islam now but now we
also see that okay as a young man all
these rules are not fitting with what
you want to do so you move over to
what's the next step here because I
thought that it's against my feet rrah
okay it's also against my nature as a
human there's so many doors on oh yeah I
don't think this is correct
yes but who are we to make any comment
because now all these teaching this
so-called
all this religious teaching is more on
tradition they are not of other thing in
wolf now it's not easy to go back to the
pure teaching you go to Guatemala is it
kind of like if you go to one village
they're doing something different from
the other one everyone's changing
changing doing some adjustment here so
then we we make another he dora the
christianity presenting my sister
they're also very involved in in a
christian religion okay so I became a
Christian and in Christianity of course
we enjoy life because in Krishna theory
almost everything is okay now you can
open seat now now you can with it we say
kick it yeah meaning like you can just
you know where freedom you're free now
just say you believe you believe it out
how the life it is okay
it's a whole thing taken care
you got the JC go-cart we put and put it
on G's best stock for the law so to us
we feel that is oh this is good yeah
this is this is more interesting in life
yeah almost you can do anything you
commit scene you just go to me some
confession and then baptize of the
hamdulillah clean again and you can just
go ahead and let your your where your
desires were loosed so this is it now
Christianity we're gonna go ahead this
is a very very interesting story and I'm
sure you're excited to hear how he came
to Islam from Buddhism to Christianity
but you're gonna have to tune in next
week for the rest of the show you think
we can continue on with part two
inshallah God willing so we'll see you
same time same channel here on the Dean
show we'll share who's saying ease his
journey to Islam peace be on TV said I'm
like I just want to say very simple
message is the Medina one of the
beautiful things about our religion of
Islam is the emphasis on direct ritual
and prayer who God directly there is no
intermediary the lights will go on after
the party and the party will end it's
very simple and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out and
we might not make it till tomorrow
and this is something that we need to
think of them coming to the truth
requires two things it requires deep
thinking that you've already done but it
requires another step and that's courage
if you have the truth but you don't have
courage you won't stand up for the truth
and that's as good as standing up for
falsehood I would say this thing that
you're just told thing it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you
I'm ready you're hosting you're watching
the Deen show thank you for tuning in to
another exciting episode last week we
had a chance to bring you sheikh
husseiny who went from buddhism to
christianity and we stopped right there
and everybody's excited to hear the rest
so when we come back you're going to
hear the rest here on the Deen show sit
tight don't go nowhere
Salam alaikum sheer walekum salam wa
rahmatullahi Brocato nice to be back
again nice to have you guys again thank
you for finding the time to be with us
here on the Deen show oh yeah Allah
we're out there we're trying to share
because we care and we're trying to help
people understand the most misunderstood
way of life in the world yet the
fastest-growing Islam submission to the
one guy yeah Allah Allah like a little
oh and and you came to this realization
that this is the truth and we're trying
to because there's Muslims all over even
in China and there was Muslims on the
moon we'd be interviewing them to Allah
so tell us now just to recap we talked a
little bit about your journey your
parents were Buddhists now and you
practice that a little bit then you came
to Christianity just to for the viewers
that weren't with us last week just kind
of bring us up to speed
bring us up to where we left off please
yeah um do like I was sharing with you
the last meeting about what we learn
from Buddhism and then how we end up
making the first Hydra from Buddhism to
Christina fidgeter what is that Haeju is
migration migration okay my agree that
maybe we are moving forward we are going
ahead in life that we keep on moving
from better to best inshallah you
mentioned the the founder of what people
attribute to Buddhism what's his name
again
Gautama Guatemalan and he had the good
yes he had the boot the wakening he was
a prince yeah he was a preemie he was
going out and trying to get enlightened
yeah because he found that something is
missing in his life
yeah life is not just enjoyment
happiness you know and just all the good
lives around thrown you but there must
be more than that so life is full of
challenge that yeah but he was not being
exposed earlier until Allah open his
heart and he was exposed to the
experience on people suffer yeah and
that's why he start to
look for an answer and that's why Islam
now when it come to Islam again Islam is
the answer for everything even a lot
safer in number oh sorry
yes wrong life start with suffering and
then there will be ease after the
suffering yes and you will suffer again
there we is again there is life so we
discussed that in part one how you sing
and being in a Buddhist family you saw
that he did actually believe in one god
yes
and you talked about that and then we
also talked about that he never called
people to worship him or take him as a
god or to give him the reverence like
God yeah no he never claimed got sheep
that way once a claim is neither he
denied God he didn't even deny God hit
nd that guy might even look in his
lifestyle he worship something he
worshiped something and he was talking
about God or any other in the karma
karma we talked about commerce that's
the destiny yeah and then he talked
about suka a doctor that's what all the
other prophet was glad tidings the glad
tiding yes if you believe in God do the
good deed a good dish you get paradise
be humble help the poor how the need is
be kind to people yes be loving be good
to the environment to the animals this
is Islam yeah is it loud submission to
the one got acquired pleased by
submitting to the owner of peace the one
God he would seem like he was yes
living that life this is the same
teaching yeah no that's right if you go
back to the teaching of when I become a
Christian if you go back the teacher of
Jesus is the same until the same thing
the same thing now that's what we left
off you were seeing that there was too
many restrictions here with the Buddhism
so now you got I mean my first migration
migration out to Christiana Christianity
okay interesting idea of course you know
we been a Christian everybody who been
crazy didn't know you can do almost
everything yes
so it is a really make life very
comfortable for you what is your own
desire what did they say you have to
believe they say that what can you
explain a little bit about their
teachings yeah it's simple in Christian
be as usually believe in Jesus his
salvation you don't have to worry about
your future anymore
when you believe in cries and then it's
okay even whatever senior commits that
you don't have to worry because he's
here to save you
he's here so he have sacrifice to
crucify his life to save you so you were
a Christian you believe this of course
when it was a crazy idea it's just
beautiful
yeah I mean easy it seemed to be very
practical yeah but when you look at the
Ikeda you know when you really want to
do more about the Creed of the Korean
Jesus in Christianity today you can very
confused now were you serious were you
seriously looking for the truth how was
your state at that time yeah and then no
when I became a Christian when I look at
the teaching is so beautiful at that
time I mean is so caring loving talk
about love love God love Jesus love
yourself love your neighbor I mean I
very interesting I mean it really moved
me yeah I say if this teaching is so
good yet the religion of love I should
bring it and share it with my people
there's how I commit myself in a
Christian missionary school and oh you
went to the missionary school yeah
because I so you are now a layman you
were going to learn not really about it
so you can share a missionary school
yeah because I feel that it's part of my
duty now it's something it's so good
it's not right for me to keep it to
myself huh it's too selfish and it's bad
yeah there's good masses of God Jesus at
that time is I must bring it back to my
own community to my friend and tell them
come come let's come back to God and
wish him the true God there's a test
there's a belief at that time so there's
someone challenges believe how did you
come to Islam now how did you how long
were you a Christian for a few years a
few years but I didn't really have any
challenges for anybody but when I want
to prepare myself I got to learn more
about I got to go deeper because worry
if I start to carry out this mission if
the people ask me I don't have an answer
oh you wanted to be more knowledgeable
yeah it's important to prepare yourself
yeah
so when I want to prepare myself then I
come across this this concept of Trinity
eternity about God the holy father the
holy Son and the Holy Ghost I called the
Holy Spirit
okay trigger because I I don't have it's
not easy for me to believe a human can
become God and why must God become a
human doesn't mean I didn't make sense
to me but there is one I we were taught
at the time is it oh I asked a father to
enlighten me the father said my son be
patient that the Holy Ghost come and
enlighten you so I was waiting waiting
in no no goals come to me so you got to
feel something you got to be yes
visited by the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit yeah that's what I was taught I
was waiting and waiting and I it didn't
happen to me in the same time because
when you want to start to carry out this
mission especially I have a lot of
Muslim friends and so said that the
Muslim Tony enter in white meat Islam so
I have nothing to do if it's not I don't
know whatever it's not
I've seen this religion belong to only
to one group of it but not for everybody
yeah so then I thought the if Chris city
is true Jesus is God and these people
don't believe that Jesus is God I think
I want to share with them this beautiful
religion now that's like you you feel
like if they don't accept this they'll
go to hell yes Oh God we believe that
because there's the only and salvation
yeah the blood of Jesus blood of Jesus
that God committed suicide actually to
save you
yeah I mean it's good thing uh-huh it
not to me at that time is good so I want
to share this good thing with my fellow
brothers or friend and then before that
I need to equip myself learn something
amor Islam
yeah I didn't learn through with the
Muslim because I want to carry this
mission this message of Jesus to them so
I got to get myself prepared and this is
the work of Allah of course this is part
of a lost other
I read the book of saving Homer I was
not allowed to read the Koran because
you know in the 60s
no Muslim don't give you Quran is you
you are not a Muslim you cannot hold the
Quran you cannot read the Quran so what
can we do
yeah so we have the opportunity to read
the book of Sayed in the home or in the
heart of the second cleave so this is
one of the Companions of the last and
final messenger sentiment kind of
problem is upon them yeah so you got a
hold of this book yes and let's take a
break right there and we'll continue on
in sha Allah shall we write back on the
D show he is to be born about 60 years
ago in former Yugoslavia Bosnia after
Second World War and imagine today you
have one child how much it's important
that we realize that Islam is a gift so
we believe that in the teachings of
Jesus what is left there is truth Nina
but the truth has been mixed up with
paganism and with nature worship and so
Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
peace be on to you welcome back to the
Dean show with shake who saying ye and
now you didn't get a hold of the Koran
which is the verbatim word of god now
now let's just take a side note this is
wrong isn't it because we as Muslims we
need to be sharing the Quran the meaning
at least with the people did they have
the meaning the translation of the crown
but they do have they do ahead but they
were still holding off yeah because they
were they were taught to believe that
this holy book of the Muslim the Quran
is only for Muslims and no Muslim had
the right to touch even to passion so
that's what they were taught what do you
say about this of course before I do and
have any comment I yeah I don't know
what is their real teacher geez LOM but
later on when I came to Islam I found
that is very wrong for him to do that
here because Allah Himself confirm in
his book in the Koran shah mardan unless
allah fear allah rod hood the leaner she
will be in a team in the hood over for
gone in a man of ramadan allah revealed
this book as a divine guidance for
mankind mankind not just the arab
shining or the taller the wider the
black for everybody everybody can see
how beautiful the Book of Allah is that
this divine guidance of Allah is for
Humanity for mankind
yes and it's very sad that the muslim
have failed you have to act upon this
ayah yeah they thought that this was
only an hour's book hour you can have
now you have nothing to do is we just in
see now we are extinct your share
his carrots so now you don't get a hold
of the verbatim word of God the Koran
but you get a hold of another piece of
Islamic literature so what happens here
and having to learn after a written and
then is a loss he died of course now you
said to Arabic words so they don't think
the not yet Muslims I don't think we're
saying some cold words here he said it
hummed in his life and he died what do
you say I'll have the lamb mean all
praise to Allah for the guidance above
given me hey Diane is guiding and you
said Allah they might think it's a moon
god no ones Allah Allah is the creator
yeah is a god to everything ok so this
is not the son of the moon on but the
Creator this young rained out the sign
ok good so please go ahead so when I
read the life history of Omar who was
once the enemy of Islam no it is known
for his he is bravery you know and then
he have didn't mean he was so determined
to kill the Prophet this is a man we
were reading this book
Omar he's the commander prophet he was
an enemy to Islam yes yes of course
and later on he was exposed to the Quran
and he heard the recitation of surah
Taha by his brother-in-law and among if
hadeya and then he became a Muslim Wow
so this is an enemy of Islam like many
people now they don't know Islam yes so
maybe just because they're following
what the media is saying so now they're
having this hatred enmity he was one of
those people and then when he came to
the Quran himself debating would have
got he got guidance he got enlightened
and he accepted Islam accept it so you
read this story and what has Dennis here
on this Quran must be very powerful so
if this Quran can change this man I
think this Quran can change me
Wow you see I I have that kind of
feeling now yes I see and then I started
to learn more what what
omorrow is starting to become the
colleague the second colleague the Tao
hate in Omar how he was taught by
Prophet Muhammad to believe in one God
one one just no buts after that just
won't leave it alone Lasha Rican don't
play with it no one won and that's
because of death
Omar was given the title by the Prophet
Sunnah Salaam al Farooq along with a man
who really distinguished her through the
right and the wrong from distinguishing
right through no playing any yeah he's a
man of his word
to the extent that the Prophet said
wherever Omar move every place that he
walked the Satan will run away yes
because the burning flame of Iman in him
a man that will not compromise will not
tolerate with any form of sharing no
setting of partners with God whatsoever
Allah God alone worship just him so
we're when I look at this town I see a
large so simple it's so straightforward
and it's so easy for you to accept that
God cannot be like any one of us no and
God cannot
peace be a form of anything but he is by
himself
say Allah is one a lot of someone
everything depend on him let me anyone
of you like neither he is a father to
anybody or child to anybody voilá me up
allahu tough one nothing is equal to him
you got you have children if you don't
want me asking yes of course and and you
have sons
I have son daughters yes but now God
doesn't have any of these similarities
no but you believe this before didn't
you as a Christian that God had a son
yes okay so that's what we were taught
yeah but of course it it makes your king
for a while uh-huh
are you sure can God be a son to
somebody's and then he become the father
himself because you're looking at your
son he's gonna grow up to have the
qualities like his father's but then did
you think sometimes well that's gonna
that's to gods then isn't it yeah sure
they have to yeah
and I of course it's not easy it's
confusing I'm get listen up because
we're gonna get confused and confuse
everybody allow so you get unconfused
and you come into Islam which is simply
the call to acquire peace by submitting
to the one God so what happens now
the more and learn about Islam the more
I read the Quran
Harry Buffy there's the end that means
there's no doubt that Quran is the truth
it's simple is simple rational rational
all your questions are answered purpose
of life al-hamdu are you going when you
die everything is clear it's clear no
one's big Uwe T dunya are Cara not when
you talk about your relation with God
but also about your relation with this
world with the environment with the
people around you it's beautiful
that's why we believe now huh that
everybody who still don't understand
Islam and hid the Muslim if they hate
the Muslim because they look at the
Muslim who show bad example of course
they steer right to hate anything that
is bad but we hope that they are just to
themselves
just open the Quran just read Greek yeah
but with an open heart open mind open
heart and then be it adjust to yourself
you be your own judge we are not here to
judge anybody we're here to share with
them to tell them that this holy divine
Book of Allah Allah under Kareem is for
them so we hope that they will read we
an open mind open heart then they will
understand are we Muslim here to promote
hatred no are we here to terrorize
people no are we here to kill no we are
here to save humanity
we are here to share with them we are
calling them they and we are praying for
them by night may Allah open their heart
I am sure if people who start to open
the Quran don't just Islam through the
people please
you get confused that's why when I talk
to my family members my sibling who are
not yet Muslim if you say the Muslim I
bet I have no comment maybe sometimes
you'll find that Muslim like you have
bad Christian but Buddhist Baptists but
you have bad and ugly everywhere if they
said Muslim I bet I have no comment but
if they say Islam is that I will not
allowed that to happen because it's not
right for the comment about Islam when
they do not know anything about Islam so
I will say please read the book of Allah
Islam is not mostly Muslim is the people
Islam is that teaching and people make
mistakes people have made mistake yeah
but Islam is perfect Islam is office
from the Korea but let's take a break
there we right back here on the Deen
show one God wishes him alone do what he
wants you to do put your desire is this
thing inside you that just wants this
and wants that and you just can't get
enough you know what you never get
enough until the dirts in your mouth
don't let it come to that be sincere and
honest ask the one who created you to
guide reach the first step put off
chasing all the women and the good times
and the parties and this and that there
is no one worthy of voice it except
Allah
don't wait you never know is this what
come today for you
Dean show with Sheikh Hussein ye now we
got a few more minutes and I have so
much to ask you but so little time so
and brief tell us
so you actually you accepted us tell us
just a moment now what happened okay you
learned this and then what did you do
what did you have to say do did you have
to go get dipped in a pool to become a
Muslim but you have to do some weird
stuff what did you have to do now to
become one who has submitted to God a
Muslim like Jesus Moses Abraham Aslam
they were the ones who submitted to the
will of God what did you have to do now
alhamdulillah after I became Muslim and
I had to know that this teaching is so
simple and it's easy to understand and
the Creed is so clear-cut that our
height is very clear
kuku Allah had say there's what God one
God one God finish and all human you
have prophets have got you're good
people they are prophet their messengers
then I found and I'm going to learn more
about this team yeah before I start my
mission again because I left to share by
nature I left to share whatever I have I
like to share with others so that's why
I get involved in the circle of studying
Islam this is after you took sure how
yes yes so tell us tell us that what did
you have to do what did you say to
become a Muslim there so simple as that
when I met up with the one of the Imam
and the mosque I have I showed him I
tell him I have the intention to be a
Muslim and then he said no probably on
the be a Muslim just me shahe what is
the law
why should one know mohammed rasoolullah
make sure declare asian of faith they
call it you know saying that I declare
from today there is Nanavati to be
worship except Allah alone the one God
the One God and the Prophet Muhammad is
the last Messenger of Allah that's the
same in Aramaic jesus said Aloha
so the same guy the same guy so if you
were living during the time of Jesus is
it safe to say that you would say the
same thing except Jesus was the
messenger then yeah Hamid is the
messenger now yes and Jesus also is
there every prophet that it's a title
given to them yes like a prophet ibrahim
khalil allah and your prophet Moses
Kalam allah prophet Jesus Aroha los
ladies
names that you just say these are title
given by God friend of your indifferent
friend of God
yeah Khalid Allah mousou a column of the
one who spoke to God one who spoke to
God Moses and the one who was one
without the father that's Jesus be upon
him peace be upon him and Prophet
Muhammad Rasulullah that means the
messenger messenger so you declare that
there's no God worthy of worship except
Allah Muhammad is the messenger
now you're Muslim yes you actually went
on to study because it's interesting the
more you studied these other man-made
faiths you saw the contradictions you
saw the ambiguity didn't make sense the
more you studied Islam you saw that it
was from the divine and you went on to
become an Islamic scholar this is
amazing you went to study and you got
learn it and now you're teaching and
preaching Islam to the world yes it's
important because knowledge is light
without knowledge that's why we are here
we believe that we like to have more
open dialogue with so-called
intellectual yeah who are not yet Muslim
because we didn't believe that there's
no compulsion in religion no compulsion
origins nobody can force you yes but it
is good for so-called intellectual
scholars in any field if you want to
talk about Islam you inviting them come
up then come to the mosque you're
welcome someone's thinking out there
they say you know what mean these are
the people who caused the 9/11 what you
gotta say about that we all know yeah no
no comment about it because it's that
what the media said this has nothing to
do the answer anything to do the seeker
as a Muslim we don't believe that the
Muslim should get involved in this kind
of a physical killing innocent people is
again the teaching of Islam did you just
hear that
this is clear yes this is no no killing
or no innocent we are here to save women
children no no no no
so this is foreign to us long yeah ok so
now I'm sure they're not yet Muslim you
can relax a little bit and then we can
start to take more of the same because
this is something a programming that the
media tries to vilify Islam and make
people a little more skillful so pre
made that people involved in the media
be fair to all of us to be fair to the
Muslim
yes if you want to know more about Islam
you must ask the Muslim scholars yes
don't ask us anybody who don't have any
sound foundation about Islam it's not
right it's not been fair
we believe this reporter this media good
people yes we only ask them to be fair
to us I learned from you I remember you
abbreviation Aslam says love all mankind
do you understand that what I asked L am
I shall live all mankind we want the
best for everybody don't we
so tell them you got 30 seconds give
them the message of Islam give them your
closing comments and advice please we
would like to call all the brothers and
sisters who are following this program
number one please try to understand the
difference between Islam and Muslim it's
important if you have the right
understanding then you know what is now
and what is the Muslim and also the
second thing you must understand about
religion and tradition the teaching of
religion is so beautiful but when you
involve tradition of code you get
confuse and lastly also you must
different between the nation and
religion religion belong to God nation
he can come there's no difference and
Islam belong to all people that mean
Islam belong to the black to the Y to
the Chinese to everybody it's not only a
religion for the Arabs and the Prophet
Muhammad SAW no no salaam remind us as
muslim number one
I hope our Muslim people also understand
the spirit of this religion he say
Johannes
in Arabic my well in a vacuum Wahid
couldn't look mean Adam o Adam in Torah
the Prophet was talking to his Ummah all
the Muslim but the way he addressed them
he remind them I say a you Anna
well then he said all Muslim or just all
Fujiyama she said I you Hannah
I mean the profits won his Ummah to
understand the masses of Islam is for
Humanity for all mankind
not only for the Muslim get your card is
only one this Allah whether you believe
in him or not it's off it's just you
choose but there's only one time and all
of you came from one family from one
father all of you from Adam and Adam
from soil or from clay and that the best
among you the prophecy is those who have
pipey not because of your color your
name but because of your faith in Allah
so we hope insha'Allah this universal
message of Islam will benefit this Ummah
this human will benefit all the nation
and we will have more peace and more
understanding by having the right
understanding about Islam read the Quran
with an open mind and open huh if you
don't have a copy of the Quran you can
contact us you can contact the didn't
show in sha allah we believe that we are
ready to share with you and send you a
copy of the Quran so we will keep on
praying for all of you who are still far
away from Allah only Allah can give
Hidayah to whom he pleased and we hope
that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will give
us peace within ourselves our family our
neighbor and may allah give peace to the
world
i mean by saying la illa allah muhammad
rasul ma and we become Muslim and Muslim
is a person who believe in peace that's
why only among the Muslim only and the
most eminent community they always greet
people with the greeting of peace
as-salaam wa alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato
and this is what i like to end my speech
shift to all the brother and sister that
i like to wish all of you assalamu
alaikum wa rahmatullah wa barakatu be
the peace of allah be upon all of you
and his blessing and his mercy
and the alligators and please integrate
yourself integrate yourself with
everybody don't isolate yourself don't
stay away from other people get close to
everybody let them know the beauty of
Islam we all know blesses me alligators
may Allah forgive us
kuqali hazard was doctrine lauhala wanna
come Felisa are Muslim mechanism first
up Pharaoh in the whole for him some
Hanukkah no homo behind a shadow la
ilaha illa anta dr. gawa
du Bellay assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh Shaikh thank you very much
we started with peace we end with peace
my peace be unto you
thank you sir yeah I love letters are
now thank you oh yeah cool ah thank you
say and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show another
Sherri's
another story shared with you of another
person coming to peace peace through
submitting yourself to the owner peace
the creator of the heavens and earth so
we hope that you got to benefit and if
you'd like to pick up the Quran dial
this number on the screen 1 800 662
Islam we'll have one shipped to you
absolutely free and we'll see you next
time here on the Deen show until then
peace be unto you
he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and the earth ever liveth he
is the first
he's the owner of Mercy eat them his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great dangers worshipping other than
Allah there is none greater
the Creator there is none greater
we